All right. Go ahead, sir. Yeah, it's
interesting because um uh Jesus Christ
said that uh many will come to him on
that day. I know you quote this verse a
lot. Matthew 7:21-23. That's one I just
referred to. Verse 23 specifically,
right? I never knew them. Say I
prophesy. I cast out demons and and all
that craziness. And Jesus will say, I
never knew you. It seem it seem in that
particular scripture Jesus Christ are
talking about those that are proclaiming
themselves to be Christians or or
people. But how do you know they're not
Christian then? How did how did you know
they're not Christian? What did Jesus
say to show they're not Christian?
No, I'm saying that they they might that
they are that Jesus Christ is talking
Christians, right? No, they're not.
You're using the term Christian too
loosely. So, someone who's not saved and
claims to be a Christian, he's really a
Christian or are you talking about true
Christians who are born of the spirit
and walk in union with Christ? But
that's the thing. Who's going to say
who's a true Christian? The very passage
you quoted, finish it. I just asked you,
how do you know those people that went
to Jesus were not true Christians?
Finish the verse. Don't just quote part
of it. It told you right there. Uh it
says, uh uh, "Depart from me, ye who
practice lawlessness." Right there. They
had no regard for the commands of
Christ, which is what I just said
earlier, that if someone says she's a
Christian, but is not following the Lord
and obeying the Lord and doing things
contrary to the Lord, how dare you call
her a Christian.
The verse you quoted just gave you the
answer that I just gave you, right? What
did I just say? Selfdeception. Selfdece.
They say we believe in Jesus, but
they're living like the world, living
like the devil, right? All
right. And so how did how do we know
that those who came to Christ were not
true believers? Jesus didn't call them
Christians. Number one, he didn't say
these were Christians. He said, "Many
will come to me saying,"Lord, Lord, but
they are people I never knew." He didn't
say, "I knew you and now I don't know
you any longer. I never knew you."
You're going to call them Christian.
Is that is that your definition of
Christian? He says, "I never knew you."
It's not I knew you. We had a
relationship and then you walked away. I
never knew you. You had nothing to do
with me. I had nothing to do with you. I
didn't know you. You didn't know me.
That's Matthew 7:23, the verse you're
quoting. And I will tell them plainly, I
never knew you. So, how are you
qualifying them as Christians? So, so
that scripture can can also mean that
there's going to be people that's out
there. Yes. That's on that's on the
pulpit that's casting out demons. Sure.
Etc. And to do Christ. Judas did that,
did he not?
Judas cast out demons, raised the dead.
And and and another thing I remember is
when Moses cast down the staff and and
Pharaoh Yeah. No, forget that. Those are
unbelievers. See, now you went too far a
left. Those are sorcerers who didn't
worship Jehovah. That is a bad analogy.
I'm just saying that I'm just trying to
say that there's like a power, a evil
deity that can try to mimic the Yeah.
What What would be a better analogy to
support your case? There can be people
who think they're Christians and still
do still do miraculous stuff, but
they're not really Christian. I gave you
one.
Judas. Judas raised the dead, cast out
demons, and he preached the gospel, and
he got people saved. That's in Matthew
chapter 10:es 1 to8. If you go to
Matthew 10:es 1-8, Judas is one of the
12 that Jesus sends out by his power and
authority to cast out demons, raise the
dead, and preach the gospel. It's right
there in Matthew 10:es 1-8. And so here
you have Judas doing miracles, getting
people saved, casting out demons, and he
still did not belong to the Lord. He
belonged to the devil.
So that's the example you use. Someone
who claimed to be a disciple of Jesus,
who actually followed Jesus, who ate
with Jesus, slept next to Jesus, heard
Jesus preached, went out in the
authority of Jesus to do miracles in
Jesus' name, even cast out demons. Just
exactly the same people. Matthew
7:21-23. Same thing. Matthew 7:21-23.
Not everyone who says to me, "Lord,
Lord, shall enter the kingdom of heaven,
but those who do the will of my father
is in heaven. For many shall come to me
in that day and say, Lord, Lord, Lord,
Lord, sovereign Lord, Adonai, Yhovah,
did we
not prophesy in your name, cast out
demons in your name, and perform mighty
miracles in your name? And I will tell
them plainly, I never knew you. Depart
from me, you walk, you you workers of
iniquity. You lawless ones, you who had
no regard for the law. Well,
Judas called Jesus Lord. Judas cast out
demons. Judas performed many miracles.
And Judas did not belong to Jesus.
So example. So to go back to your
question, not to drive, but I just want
to make sure if you have a sister, if
you have a sister that is justifying
dressing in a very pro provocative way
where she's basically naked to cause men
to sin and stumble, then that person has
not come under the conviction of the
spirit and has not surrendered to
Christ. That person may come under
conviction and surrender Christ and
change later on. But for all intents and
purposes, I don't know of anyone who
says they love Jesus but will
justify sinning against Jesus and
breaking his heart. To give an analogy,
let me give you an analogy. It's like
marriage. Okay? And women can identify
with this because this is one of the
complaints of women. If a if a husband
tells a woman that he loves her and
she's, you know, his world, but he
doesn't spend time with her,
only comes around when he wants to sleep
with her, ignores her wishes and does
things to break her heart, that woman is
going to see clearly that man doesn't
love her. That man is only using her to
gratify his own sinful passions. That's
what you're telling Jesus. When you tell
Jesus you're my Lord, but you don't do
what he asks you to do and you keep
doing things to grieve his heart, to
grieve his Holy Spirit, and you're a
stumbling block to others where you
cause others to sin against God and
prevent them from knowing the God that
you profess to love. You don't love
Jesus, you're lying. End of story.
Interesting. Because I know there was a
female, she uh said, "Why don't you stop
chasing her, bro? It sounds like you
like her and you want to repent. There's
no missionary dating. Give it up,
brother.
No. No. No. She's She's uh she's I don't
even really know her. She would just say
in her testimony.